He's a great standup.
I'd done tours with him before I've done many shows with them.
We've been in battles. We fought and where we scream at each other.
Um, but you know, he's been in many battles, actually.
He had an infamous battle with Dan cook outside his apartment. One time.
Remember that?
Yes.
Ladies and gentlemen. He's a headliner.
I'm from Pittsburgh originally and he's a dear friend and I'll know her.
I'll know him for the rest of my life. His name is Steve Byrne.
Give him a round of applause.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. You're welcome. Okay.
Yes. Um, thanks for doing my podcast. Yeah.
I feel like I've done it already. Yeah. Has he done the podcast before?
We've talked about him so many times. I do talk about you a lot. Yes.
Have I said good things? No,
that's just a bad thing. So yeah, those things get back to me, but I, yeah,
I know you though. So I don't, I know how you are, so I don't. Oh,
how am I? Well, even when you said, like we've had our battles.
Okay. I think I come at things from like, uh,
like a pragmatic kind of like, you know, I don't get my emotions involved.
I think when we talk,
there have been times where emotionally I'm confused by the decisions you've
made. But I just say,
I've never like when we've argued,
I've never left a conversation saying you just burned a major bridge.
I don't do like that. And I've said that you said that
you said that to me as you walk to like a Corolla and sped out a 30 miles per
hour of the company. Okay. Yeah.
My car has nothing to do with this kind of business.
I burned a major bridge Hollywood power player.
Bobby Lee Toyota, Corolla and speeds away.
What was it before Corolla? You're right. Oh, wow. I'll tell you what a,
what a great friend. This is. He knows. I love Oasis love.
This is one of the things that irritates me, but I, again, I like, I don't,
I don't get, I don't say you burn a major bridge. I just go to this Bobby,
his car, your car broke down or something. Right?
Did your car broke down Corolla? Yes. Yes. Thank you.
Probably that night as he was leaving. Yeah. Um,
and then I had a Honda Santa Fe at the time and I was doing the
purple. No, it was silver. Oh yeah. So the reason why I thought it was purple.
I'm not from Minnesota. So I led to, I said, Hey, take my car.
I'm going on the road, use my car while I'm gone. Does that.
So I think about what, who does it a comic, a friend, whatever,
a friend, a friend, whatever, a friend.
When you burn the bridge at Burnett and take time to rebuild,
starting to rebuild. Right? So, so I lend them, my car, my car, he,
I get back in my car and I go to a play. My Oasis.
I go, where's my Oasis DVDs. Not one, not two, like three Oasis DVDs.
I call, I go CDs. I go by where's my, I threw them out the window. Oh my
why? Because I told you because you don't listen.
I lend you my car and I let you listen.
This is who I deal with. I'm the bad guy, but that's the thing.
I got another one. You guys ready for? Another one real quick, listen,
no wasted. Right. And then we'll move on to other things. But you don't listen.
Right? I, I don't like the band. Okay.
Why is it tampered all over the thing? Like,
like it's a flyer for some sort of nightclub or something.
Now I love them now, but at the time.
I didn't like them. I thought they were like too poppy, but I liked them now.
I apologize. How much money do I owe? 60 bucks. Okay. All right.
So what's the second thing I did. Oh, Oh, well,
I'm sure you now I have so many things that you have.
Okay, good. Good. What? You will go tit for tat ahead. Oh,
you want me to put her down? All right. All right. Let's look at the cat.
Then this guy calls me. Right. And he goes, get it over with,
because I was on a sitcom.
Animal practice. It got canceled and I was really hurt by it. Sure.
It was a really tough time because, um, I didn't have Khalilah at the time.
And, um, that was.
I called you the night of premiere. I bet you don't remember that. I know.
Thank you. I watched it. I said, congratulations. He doesn't make,
he forgets these things. This, this, ideally this next part. Yeah. Right.
So I watched it.
He calls me, he goes, sorry about animal practice, but you know, I have a show.
I go, yeah. Sullivan and son. Right. Because I was thinking about, you know, um,
you know, writing a character with UNL,
like so reoccurring and it's going to be really cool. And you know, um,
you know, at the time a med was on it,
the wonderful and the multifaceted Owen, Benjamin,
you know what I mean? Just the pure talent that he is, of course.
And I go, yeah, you're gonna ride.
You know, you know, when somebody calls you for something like.
That, you start,
you lay down in bed and you start fantasizing what it's going to be like at the
Warner brothers lot. You know what? It's like rehearsing,
laughing with your friends. You're actually working. You're on TV with your,
you know, there's nothing better. Right.
And then three months later I find out Ken Jong is doing it.
Did that, that did that. Did that happen? You're old. You're old pals.
So my thing is, is this okay? I know why that happened.
No, you think, you know why it happened and you bring this up. I love it.
You're wrong. You're tired right now. Your eyes you're getting wasteful.
[inaudible] let me get you the age fully tired. You better
[inaudible].
I know. Okay. So it doesn't make any sense. Okay.
But we're in a different planet right now. Okay. And so if you look at like,
you know, we'll be Goldberg's vagina, right. If she's using it,
I bet it's more Goldberg than would be the.
I bet it seems aggravated.
Yeah. But I'm sure if she uses it, it looks fine. That's all,
I'm not a scientist, but your labor is not a muscle. Yeah.
Do you ladies on a muscle. You cool. You cool? Yeah.
But I know we're honeycombs from me.
So we both win. We both lose. Where'd you say, honey comes from,
what was your auntie called? Woods? In the woods, but in honeycomb. Yeah.
Rodney comb. Where did that come from? You kook. You come, you want to call me?
[inaudible] you guys edited that in, in there? Yes you did.
We have it on factual files, dude. That's not a real thing. Factual.
[inaudible] isn't there a drawing that's supposed to happen right now,
downstairs and in the ship lobby. Can we get him a job
closed? Yeah. Ladies and gentlemen, uh,
the buffet is close. Well, we were in Hawaii. A lot of people do look like you.
A lot of Filipinos work on the cruise ships.
In the hotel. They all just kind of have your like bland look.
Yeah. Why don't you call me bland? I didn't at all.
I feel like it's a kind of an Island mahogany. Ooh. I like that.
Work at, uh, you know, I could see it like at ABC. If you saw me in a hotel,
you know, working there, you'd be like, yeah, that guy's weird.
Nobody can imagine you work.
That's so.
You even say something like that. Let me say something right now. Okay. Let me,
I used to work on a farm. Did you know that? An ant farm?
[Inaudible].
That's cute. That's cute, man. No, man. A real farm.
Oh yeah. Well, were you guys growing, dude, honey.
The corn dude. Oh, really? Heard of corn. Yeah. Yeah. I used to work at a farm.
I used to work at a farmer's market.
Or you just set a pharmacy or you're just saying things.
Used to work construction. I used to wait tables. I used to do a lot of jobs.
You really? And I was a hard worker. Okay.
I don't it's only when showbiz got into my vein that I haven't really
worked one vein. I believe that park one vein.
One way in one way out.
A upper lip then. Yeah. Do Marvel lips. So dude, unless.
Lester Holt has a very thin upper lip and he's had a good, yeah, he does have,
have you noticed that about yourself when you look in the mirror though? Yeah,
but my body took everything. Yeah, it did. Yeah. Yeah. I just have a greed.
Not fully formed. Is it? Uh, that,
that tuna what's tuna called Nike. Nike? Yeah. Japanese. What's it called?
The Japanese Maki marquee. Mama. Lucky. Here's the thing about you too.
Oh, what about you too? Oh, no sir. Cause he really
lost his voice. Well,
you just said here's here's the thing about YouTube here it is.
They're just great. I thought I was going to say, Oh,
I didn't know you bottle was saying.
Or is he like sick?
He got a tracheotomy. No way.
The top story does say bono says he doesn't know if YouTube will tour again.
Wait, but he has a trait. Like he actually has a hole in his.
Yeah, I remember that. That movie, no country for old man.
And that guy had that gun that would shoot holes through doors. Bano got hit,
got a hole in his throat from that. Oh, not from an Eric.
I think he just says a sore throat them. Sorry.
He just has a sore throat. I know.
But you can read the news and make up your own.
All right guy. No, no country for old men. No country for Bano.
Whoa. He's got Ireland.
I wonder if Bano gets a morning Bano?
Yeah, maybe, maybe. Yeah.
Oh wait. He did have throat cancer in 2000.
Ha ha.
You're right. You're right. You're right.
But the second brush with mortality had nothing to do with his throat.
It was a high energy bicycle accident.
You didn't do his throat.
[inaudible] man. Who was he laying on the sidewalk? I don't know.
Maybe they're like little tiny bite elf bikes. Ooh,
those hurt you also go to burning man, right? Yeah. Do you go every year?
I went three years in a row. I didn't go this year,
but the last three before that I regretted not going this year. I really,
I wait. I woke up every morning going, why aren't I there?
Uh, first year I kind of went by myself and the second
year I went with my buddy Michael Rosenbalm and then last year I went
with my buddy Dan and uh, I think I'm going to go next year.
You know, it's funny. I there's such a stigma, you know,
on like just people who go to burning man in general, like, you know,
the LA types. But I never, if there was a,
you seem like the perfect person to go to burning man with. If I ever,
if I could ever think of anybody, I would want to go with you seem like.
Nope, she's not going with you. She is,
but she's not gonna do it.
I wouldn't allow it selfish.
I am selfish. And when it comes to that dude.
Why can't I take your girlfriend away in a camper for five
days? What's wrong with you?
That's my girl. Okay. Uh, okay.
Mr. Scrooge humbug.
Call me Mr. Scrooge, bro. Yeah.
Why can't I walk in a camp or with your beautiful girl?
What would you do? What would you do out there with her in the desert?
Like that?
Ask her, what would you do with Harlan Williams.
Waltz around the Playa cook. Good food baby. You know.
Hey, wait. I need to know.
I do need to know man, because I know you're out there. They don't take money.
They trade services. Once you want to get a sandwich,
you got to sell her a little bit.
Just stop right now. Whoa, bro. You want a sandwich?
You got to tell my little girl's out his eyes
for a meatball sandwich. You this round
one, this right. Don't.
Do that, dude. That's human being right there.
Man.
Do not see that.
So two weeks ago he was playing Ontario and he goes, Hey, do Sunday. I go, okay.
And then I never used to go. I was in two weeks, I was at the wind,
whatever the wind three sold out. How many seats, how many people,
that one was close to.
That was 6,000 total seats sold out six months.
So what we've learned today is this. What we learned today is this.
We've learned a lot of things today, but we've learned that, um,
that you know a relationship isn't a two-way street. You know,
sometimes when you have two people,
one's more generous than the other.
And so I think by the facts of this trial and in
this case, right, it,
it shows that I'm the one that's being harmed.
I'm the one that gives and doesn't receive what the. I'm the one. Listen.
Any of your.
Listeners got that? None of your listeners got that from this show.
Not one person that's listening.
Yeah they did because they're my fans.
They're my fans too. Okay. And they get me, you know,
after you know how to tell you this, my friend, I'll tell you this,
my friend might write what I can't do two weeks in Ontario,
but I could sell out a weekend. And those people that come to my shows. Yeah.
Don't you love me. Do they love you? And I'm giving them a message.
What it has nothing to do with you. What I'm saying to you, people right.
Is interrelationship. One person, right.
Is more giving sometimes than the other person and the other person. Right.
Being an Island, an Island, [inaudible] right. Being an Island.
They suck up the energy sometimes. Ah, wow.
I've been to Korea. I've been,
I've been to the Philippines to France.
[Inaudible] Korea. I love, I love that.
And I love the Korean. I love your mud rivers. And I love the fact
that your girlfriend.
Go ahead. Tell me about Korea. I love what you guys love you guys too. So much.
The 33% of the country that you can work.
I love the fact that here, Oh man, you're talking about that right now. I'm just
What you guys get to do you get this much?
This much goes to golf courses.
And then this goes to a guy that looks just like you eat on the
Northern part of interesting. So enjoy whatever that is. That,
that area down there in the South.
You guys traveled together.
I want to see you go to the Philippines with Joe and maybe he can go with you.
Philippines. I would see to it. You know what I love. Okay. You know,
here's what, this is what it'll help me. And I'm being real.
Let's hang up each other and go to Korea and the Philippines that'd be great.
I swear to God. That was so be so funny. All right. So I'm, I'm, I'm at work.
Right? And I go to the comedy store. No, I was on my television network. Job.
Yeah. Telephone television network.
The lady that's doing my hair and I'm like, I just,
I don't know why I throw this up. I go, well, will you last week? She goes, Oh,
I took a week off. My favorite festivals in Las Vegas.
So me and my husband went and what kind of she's like, uh, I guess, you know,
sort of doom rock festival, heavy metal. Right?
I don't pay attention. Yeah. Yeah. And I go, ah, she's like, it's.
Funny because there was a couple.
Of comedians that went up. It's a chicken gigantic.
Oh, I just, it just hit me.
There was a big festival that we went over and did. That's what you did.
Okay. Go ahead. I didn't know it, my head. I forgot. I did that.
So when it complimented, you didn't even know what the I was talking about.
Yeah. So I'm like, Oh, I go, Whoa, who the comedians?
And she goes, well.
No, I don't like dies. I love dice. But it's like dies. He was okay. And I,
and I go, okay. But there was a girl before that went up and I got [inaudible].
She was very funny. And in my head I dies.
And then when she said there could only be one. No. And I'm like,
it's my second ex fiance. I know. And I go, is it? And I Googled juror,
is it her?
She gets debts. Right.
So then when I see her, you know.
Later, a couple of days later I take podcast and I go in and I go, Hey,
reps, the podcast I interrupted, I just walked in and I go.
Hey, hair, lady. You know, she was at the Vegas. And she said, you, you great.
And you go, huh? Like you do.
I go, thanks, man. I know you me off. First of all, you on it.
The whole time
that you on it the whole time then gave the compliment. Like no way it can't be,
it can't be that somebody saw Eleanor and she was good. her. I hate her.
[inaudible] say it. And you're like, I gave you a compliment. I'm like,
you didn't give me a compliment.
She did. Yeah. But I, the information I know, but.
You just reiterated it to me. Don't come at me.
I know. I know. But can I just say this though? All right. Is it,
I didn't have to give you that information.
I kept it inside when I ride at night.
And I go and I go, I'm going to make this pitch. That'd be, feel good. Right?
Filthy white. And so I throw it out there and I just don't.
I didn't like the responses. That's all.
Wait, did it really hurt your feelings? Cause I didn't mean to,
but we were on a podcast. So you know, I'm.
I was kidding too. Okay. But you don't watch game of Thrones? No,
I don't watch that kind of stuff. What do you mean?
Just people fighting in the past and all of that weight.
Is that a historical document about the past?
This is something that really had no, it's not. Yes. I don't want Elizabeth. No,
it's not that kind of stuff.
Bro. [inaudible] maybe I'll read.
Up on it a little bit. Look at me. No, no, no. You know what, dude,
I'm tired.
I'm tired too, man. What time is it? I.
Know. I know arms hurt too. No, no, no.
You're good.
We'll do a couple more minutes. Yeah. Yeah.
I am going to do a couple more minutes while I grill you. Okay.
Grill away, dude. Oh, well dude. All right.
I'm tired of your. Wake up with the King. This dude.
It's making burgers over here.
Right? Right. You liked it. You know what you like to do?
You'd like to destruct me. I do word games, dude.
Yeah. You don't do that again. Either. It gets away from it.
It's a couple of pieces of glass.
You have too much warning blips way too much morning.
Hey this morning bro. Yeah. It's starting a hell of an afternoon in my.
I will say that. What I'm saying is daylight savings.
Time in my. Yeah.
But you know, you look nice tonight then. No, don't do that right now.
I'll do that right now.
No. What I'm saying to you is this, okay, this is this. Okay. Is that,
what did I say that a lot, right? Yeah. I'm sorry. No, don't be apologize.
It's not a bad thing. All right. Is it's a great show.
I think you'd really like it. It's like in terms of pop culture.
I think there's not a better show out there.
No, I mean game of Thrones. Oh yeah. I haven't seen it. I know you haven't.
Oh wow. I have no, I'm not going to let him do it.
He's not in a Groundhog yet. Little guy. No,
you're doing defense mechanisms that you do. Right.
And then you try to divert me and I go, Oh yeah. Okay.
I guess it's like Jedi mind tricks, but I'm Jabil. It doesn't work with me.
That you're just. I didn't do it.
I'm not doing anything, dude. Oh my God. You're a dummy.
You're a bright young man. You watch it.
Watch it. You don't watch it, dude. All right. Oh,
what are these prescription pills on the table? It's for my panic attacks. Well,
yeah.
[inaudible] yeah, I dude, I'm about to stroke out, back off the T what is it?
A drug that they're always putting in, uh, Asian people's food.
[inaudible] back off the MSG. Daddy,
you out there putting speakers in your car pocket. Sipping on soy sauce, dude.
Back off. Good advice. You should scale back on.
I'm going to scale back on the soy sauce. Okay.
Right now we're getting somewhere. All right. But I listen. Right?
You gave me a suggestion. I listened. Yeah. I'm sorry. No, don't apologize.
Cause there's nothing to apologize for. All right.
You're going to watch game of Thrones. Okay. I'll watch it. Every episode.
No bro. No. Ah, yes. Okay. Oh yeah.
Yeah. Shouldn't have said, okay.
Yeah, you sit. Okay. And that's a problem. How many episodes are there?
Seven seasons.
Man.
So 10 seasons in an episode. 10 episodes. 70 of us.
And what's it about?
It's about the past, the past.
I got to do, man.
You're going to do it. I'll watch some of it.
Oh they are so sensitive about that.
I just don't get it. Bobby. I know you, you play on the, um,
on the funny all the time. Like you play on the funny,
but I it's got to offend you win. Cause you're you're a shock comic. Like you,
you do like to say what's on your mind. You do hate me. That look.
There's a bunch of words you said before this show started. Yup. Yeah,
we do. Do we not have to edit book?
I want to say this. Do we not have to edit a bunch of words?
But you want to talk about.
You want to talk about that was said before we even started this thing.
We'll tell you something right now. I know,
but I'm gonna tell you something right now.
Dude. All right. I say up. Things like that.
So I don't say it on the podcast so I can just get it out. Okay. I'm purging it.
All right. Got it. Right. God man. You pepper.
Is that my camera? Yeah. I also was. I wanna just I to say to you that, um,
yeah, go ahead the first time.
Yeah, no, no. I know. You've heard some things. I said this.
The only reason I'm here. That's your little tag, a belly crew
being misinformed. What did you call you? People. The tag of Belize,
black sleepers slept keto sleep sleep was, had been lied to what is the lie?
Go ahead. I saw this little clip.
Do the Brown in there and your little office with the sycophants
and Michael Bisping. He just didn't know me or anything.
That's not how it went down at all. No, first of all, Michael,
I want to say this doesn't look any different to sitting down.
[inaudible] it's like you leaned forward. I was very funny.
Very funny. But let me say, I'll tell you the way it went down.
Give your version and I'll give mine for the, what did they call it again?
Okay. So every course, every one.
Well, because you know, Joe Rogan is a standup. He's a long time friend of mine.
I've known him for 20 years, 25 years. Um, love him. Great guy.
But um, so a lot of, you know, I'm a huge UFC fan.
So who's that little guy from Sacramento. I like [inaudible] right.
You're a father, a man. He's a nice guy. We hugged this and that.
But then when I saw Bisbing Michael, you for the first time there,
I literally was struck. I was just like, Oh.
That's Michael Bisbing right.
And I try to come up to you and I sit and you were very nice, but I said,
Hey man, I'm a big fan. And you were, you know, because when I walk,
I was at the grocery store and people come up to me and go, Oh,
you're very funny. And you want to be cordial. Right. But I also,
if that person that said hi to me was Josh Groban. Right.
And right. Okay. And I blew him off. Right.
I bet that Josh Groban would probably be a little mad.
So he was at the comedy store where.
I don't know who judge, I've got zero context of what you're saying.
[inaudible] opera singer. I'm always at the opera. Right. So when Michael,
his business there.
He said very nice, but he could have just walked away. And I wanted some,
you know what I mean?
No, I didn't really, but he did walk away
version of this story already. And here's the reality. And I'm not,
when I say this, by the way, by the way, massive fan. Hence why I'm here.
Head's wire drove up from orange County audition and I waited for three and a
half hours get five to 30. I was half asleep, half an hour ago. Okay.
Just partner some coffee. Now I'm drinking this shake. Try and stay awake.
And I'm very happy to be here. You have the hilarious comedian.
I never met you before. Okay. Hold on.
Get into the pie. The lung suffering. Mrs. Bisping.
That's at home. God bless her. She doesn't get out very often.
She's got three kids. I travel a lot. I took her out.
We went out for a nice dinner and went to go watch some comics and a lot of the
time. And I'm not trying to say that I'm a big dealer or anything like that.
But a lot of time you stop and you take pictures and this and that.
And then after a while you got to say, okay,
because I'm here with my wife and I'd done about 10 pictures in a roll while
she's standing there like a lump of cheese. Right. Doing nothing.
So then after that, I'm like, okay, all right. All right, bet. Let's go in.
And then you, after that say now, sorry mate, we're done pick your time is all
right. You should start doing now. Let me say something. Right? So when you, Oh,
not fair. Sorry if I didn't put a random stranger before my wife.
I'm so sorry. I know you're the gray
and the company's stories, your house and you're totally right.
It is your house, but we'd never met. And that's the mother of my children.
And the way.
I accept your apology, you're, it's fine. It's fine.
paws out of my face right now. You weren't, you weren't.
He was devastated though. He called.
Me immediately ran to the parking lot and he was like, you can't,
you won't believe what happened.
Go for what?
Right. But no, but could I say this please? Can I say this, please go ahead.
You did give me a photo.
I did. Yes. I remember it. I was standing over the barrel. Yes.
With Diaz. And I walked up because when you were talking to Diaz, you know that,
then I see as my opportunity and we took the photo, you know what?
I was just talking out of my. Right. Just talking or whatever,
thinking that you're ever going to hear. Right.
It's okay. I do it all the time. If I was held accountable,
every piece of dog that came out of my mouth,
I'd probably be in prison or ex-communicated from whoever I know.
And you know, I want to say this too, is, is that.
Never let the truth get in the way of a good story. Right. You know,
I've never heard it before, but Chinese proverb,
Asians like that, man, what do you mean with the Asian, Chinese? Proper?
[inaudible] that.
Fight right. Was crazy.
I don't want to talk about you, but here's what I do want to talk about. Okay.
What about you? But I have a couple of other quotes. I want a favor.
And my favorite is the next time you do a gigantic show, like at a theater show.
One of your like stadium.
Bobby. Where's my
there's Mo this multi-camera the small, tight I have offered.
I have offered every show that I've had. I said, Bobby,
just walk on stage. You don't have to ask. You don't have to tell anybody.
Just walk on. And what do you say every time? No,
you don't. Does he say that he hasn't replied? He never replies.
You're a piece of. I know. And that's okay.
That's the, mine's my camera.
Is it the one behind me or the one directly in front of you in the mirror.
So you look at that camera. I'll look at this one.
So what you tell me, you tell me, Bobby, sorry.
Tell me.
So I'm saying to you right now, people, okay. Listen to me right now.
I'll tell me. And you have the facts.
You've listened to this podcast from beginning to end and be right.
Be honest and know in your heart, know, in your heart. Listen to the facts.
Okay?
Don't do it for fun. You know,
going on goalie on his side would only be for fun. Filipino liar.
He's a liar.
This goes around all over the world theaters, right?
I've asked for some.
Emotional help. Oh, I like your podcast. Kidding me.
Give me nothing. And then last week you're gonna have a Netflix special.
Can you do target? But like I'll clear Monday for you. You. Cause I love you.
I sold 400 meters out in Hawaii.
[inaudible] you don't deserve it. Sometimes. You don't deserve it sometimes.
Anyway. Anyway, what are we on time? Oh, that was it Howard.
Nope. Can we get through this on helpful advice? Yeah. Oh my God.
How come you never watched the cartoon?
How did you miss out on that? Oh, is that good?
Gilbert, look at me. It's that good? That I'm missing out.
You know what? I'll watch that tonight. I'm not mesmerized.
If it's not light bulb right?
The next day he's singing all the songs around the house, but you're already,
I'm going to tell you, I'm going to tell you.
I would. I think it's about okay. Okay. There's a man. Yes.
He's some sort of curse. Okay. Right. And he turned into a Buffalo,
whatever it might be. Yeah. Okay. Goat, Buffalo. All right. And then,
and then there's like a salt shaker.
Okay. [inaudible].
Sicker a light bulbs. A soy sauce bottle is Japanese.
Yeah.
You know what I mean? And a, um, old, old timey trash cans.
Right.
They come alive and they start because what I assumed that he was a
King and those were all his like compatriots or whatever.
And there's some sort of curse. They turned into shot, salt, shakers.
He turned into a goat. Right. And they're bummed.
They're livid because you can't live like a salt shaker. You know what I mean?
You're just shaking the whole time you're walking around. You know what I mean?
People know when you're coming. Yeah.
[Inaudible].
All right. And then, you know, the gold meets, there's a lady,
a girl comes in into town. She's fresh. She's fresh into town.
She fray. Right. She comes through the, you know, the castle,
she meets this goat and she's scared at first. Right. She's like,
ah, man, just go creature. I don't wanna be around it. You know?
And then they fall in love and something happens at the end.
There's a bunch of songs. Okay. Thousands of songs they sing. Yeah. Yeah.
And then at the end,
something happens where he turns back into human and they fall in love.
But do I have the gist?
I feel like you've watched it and you're playing it off. Like you did it now.
I'm going to say this right now. God.
On my life that I've never seen it.
That's conviction in his eyes. I believe God. On my operas life ask my brother.
I've never seen any of that. Right?
Accused me. You broke your iPad.
You just accused me of treason against.
Against my speech. My race, not my race, my gender.
The male gender. I've never, no one ever accused me of piercing looking.
Don't tell him. So Mike, do I have to just.
Yes. You're pretty good. That's amazing.
We'll just give him more movies and see.
And um, let's just bury the hatchet with everything. Okay.
I know everyone has say it again. Okay. In other podcasts, we're ending it now.
Whatever, because there's a lot of purity and goodness that comes from you.
Yeah. I mean, I haven't talked about you at all,
but you're the one that talks about me.
So when you're saying we bury the hatchet, you bet,
you bet you do. Okay. Let me rephrase this. The screencap of,
let me rephrase that. And this is what it is. Okay. Yes. I,
you could have just let it go with that.
I could have said we bury the hatchet.
No, we could have just moved onto the next thing. Right.
But then you had to add in right. You bury it. I know whatever.
That's what it sounded like you the hatchet, where, where,
where have you ever been?
Where you're like word on the street is burns talking on. Like, where's that?
No, because just have more of a rat pack style perhaps.
But I don't like Sebastian Maniscalco in that way, you guys have like a real,
like I just keep to myself, like the rat pack, like a team,
they don't, you know, meet you. Don't rat your friends out, you know,
like mafia stuff. Right.
He has those things and I'm the guy that dies five minutes into
the mafia movie. Right. I get stabbed a thousand times by pencil,
just in the first five minutes of the movie. That's how,
because I'm a talker and I'm a coward. Right. But you know,
you know, I'm okay. Yeah. But let's just bury it now I'll bury the hatchet.
Okay. Since you didn't, you don't have a hatchet, I'll bury the hatchet.
Y'all bear for life and then you and I can move on. Yes. Right. But you know,
watch it. I'm not afraid to,
you know, you know, I love you though. That's what you're here.
You know? I love you. Listen, you have, you do know that correct.
For the fact that he does get especially triggered by you because I think he has
a deeper love for you than he has for compared to other people.
Because when he had you guys had that weird thing at the comedy store. Yeah.